all right thank you for attending today
my name is Zach Bend I'm the director of
consumer product development here at
tonight's Chanel mix and I've also been
fortunate enough to being the lead for
the visiting spatial gene-expression
solution as we do development here so
what I want to convince you of today is
that spatial context is important and
also like to start these seminars I was
quote from David Craig and UC University
Southern California he says everything
everyone is waiting for spatial context
you can only learn so much and really
what this means that without the idea of
what sells around what other cells you
don't have any idea of you know
basically how the cells are interacting
what Stella you're talking to what cells
and how far apart other cells are from
one another and so this is a great
example here why we want to do spatial
analysis these the paper this is a paper
from salts at all in 2018 and
essentially what they did is they have a
pathologist scored these and showed that
there has been two regions that had or
cancerous the region a up top shows a
good lymphocyte infiltration of the
tumor and that actually took good
prognosis whereas on the bottom you see
you have the same tumor as identified by
pathologist and what you notice is that
the lymphocytes don't actually get into
the tumor they're kind of forming this
ring around it and if you were looking
at state another data using single-cell
analysis you really wouldn't be able to
tell the difference between these two
phenotypes and this is critically
important that you understand how these
differences because one obviously to a
better outcome than the other so it's
very important to understand the spatial
relationship of these cell types within
these tissues of interest so it's like I
said in this case so we overlay the gene
expression data with histological hme
images the good thing about the spatial
analysis and you don't have this
association bias so in many cases
dissociating tissues can leave you with
a lack of certain cell types and the
overabundance of other cell types that
aren't nationally
within those tissues in those abundances
but certain ways that the Association
works
he basically end up with a non
representative population retains the
organization and tissue in the cellular
microenvironment so again you can kind
of see which cell we're talking to what
other cells and you can look at the cell
type identification in the context of
this heterogeneous tissue so I really
look at spatial is kind of evolution of
RNA seek you know what's been going on
in the field for the last decade or so
and what you started out with you know
ten twelve years ago was a bulk RNA
stick where you could take your tissue
of interest associated the whole thing
into its RNA component and then you run
that through a sequencing and that was
interesting you get a lot of averages
and it's kind of represented here by a
single spot on a TCE plot where you
actually don't learn that much about
what's actually happening but getting an
average at all the gene expression
within that tissue with the advent of
single cell you were actually able to
see what kind of cells or part of that
tissue while speaking disability a
tissue and look at the individual cell
types that are present however with
spatial you can actually see visually
where the cell types are present within
the context of the tissue and this
definitely allows for better
understanding the tissue morphology and
cell the cell interactions so what is
spatial transcriptomics the basic
concept here is that you can take a
standard glass microscope slide the
slide has these barcodes bar coded spots
printed on it in an ordered fashion such
that each barcode we know the location
of it on the surface and jump those are
the sequencing handle and the
holiday-themed capture area you can do
your first transcription on the slide
and after reverse transcription you can
take that cDNA and process it through
very standard library preparation
protocols and end up with the library
that can be sequence on your standard
short reads sequence there on the back
end so this is you know the very basics
of how it works and we'll
quite a bit more detail as we proceed
through the talk so first I kinda want
to go through what the Disney and
spatial gene expression solution is what
the product is what we're trying to sell
here and convince you that you know this
is a good thing to be looking at also if
you look at the original protocol from
the company spatial transcriptomics
though this was a company that connects
acquired about a year ago and we look at
the original kind of data here looking a
mousehole factory blog you can see that
there's very high gene expressions
during the region but you don't get a
very good idea of morphology of the
tissue Kevin just looks like a blob and
this is because of relatively low
resolution in this case you're only
maxing out at about 14,000 new mais per
feature we can look at the improvements
first batch is made with a visiting
product and we basically x 5x the number
of features in that same space on so as
you get much finer resolution in this
case you can actually see that there's
two distinct national factory globe and
you can even see some of the distinct
features the morphological features of
the olfactory bulb in this case we're
topping out at over 80,000 you mais per
feature
so we've greatly improved the
performance overall since the original
spatial transcript on which product a
wool we're offering is bursting spatial
tissue optimization sliding agent kit
this allows you to optimize for
different tissues and we'll go into a
bit more detail a few slides on what the
tissue optimization kit is used for and
why you need to use it before you start
a experiment and also the visiting is
basically an expression slide and
reagent kit and this is comes in two
flavors a for reaction kit which
contains one slide and a 16 reaction kit
which contains four slides and each
slide in this case contains or capture
and speaking to four samples per slide
so let's talk about teaching
optimization why you want to do this
because
your first experiment because we start
with this product the first thing you
want to do is understand how your tissue
works and I'll point out through the
course of this talk but every tissue is
unique and even every lab is a bit
different from you know each other so
you really need to focus on doing this
as a first step the basic odor the acid
is pretty simple on do your cross
sectioning I'll take it fresh frozen
tissue you place that tissue section on
these eight different capture is there
while you do your standard H&E imaging
or H&E staining followed by bright field
imaging and this allows you to see if
your sectioning conditions your staining
conditions and your imaging conditions
are also properly for the downstream
experiment after you're done you're
standing and imaging are you running
permeabilization time course and you can
test we basically recommend from 0 to 36
minutes of personalization however
depending on the tissue type you happen
to be studying I may want to go longer
or shorter or go into tighter windows
based on your knowledge of your tissue
that you're working with
after / mutilation on sliding doing
reverse transcription and do the reverse
current transcriptions that you're
adding fluorescently labelled
nucleotides into the growing C DNA
strand after reverse transcription is
complete you're removing tissue into
matically and then what you're left with
is a physical imprint of the tissue in
the form of fluorescent all egos so
these are fluorescent C DNA molecules
they actually show you living nice think
the structure of the tissue that was
above it you take your fluorescent image
and you decide which of the images in
your criminalisation time course is most
appropriate to afford with so here's
kind of overview of the workflow the
whole workflow takes less than six hours
but you start with your tissue section
on the slide you can see in the first
white image you stain that I would
Beijing II you can see now in the second
slide image and you take your
fluorescent image after you've done your
transcription and you can see through
the course of the feminization time
course that you see varying levels and
increasing levels really of fluorescence
in step and the dots in the lower right
hand corner is actually a positive
control in this case you can use the
positive control this would be total RNA
from the organism you're studying and
spotted directly on to the capture area
and allows you to see that if your
reagents are working in the case that
you're having trouble determining
permanent relationship practice on the
slides itself has eight capture areas
this allows you to do negative that
positive control or a negative control
and seven different optimization times
the capture area here contains an even
long of all waiting the capture probes
without spatial barcodes so this doesn't
give you any kind of spatial information
there's really only used to show you
what your tissue criminalisation Edition
should be you test a range of
termination conditions our initial
recommendation is 0 to 36 minutes
however depending on the tissue again
may want to go longer our reverse
transcription incorporates a 4/4 and the
cDNA strand and really what you're
looking for here is the brightest image
that has the least amount of diffusion
so what you can see here on the right is
an example of a mouse small intestine
that we knew ran here in house where
from the negative control in which no
criminalisation in them was at it out to
36 minutes according to what you see
down there below and as you can see 3
minutes you're definitely not seeing
much of the tissue and then you go 6 12
18 24 you see brighter and brighter
images beyond 24 minutes though you're
not really seeing things get any
brighter and Tribble is zoom in more
closely you could actually see that the
later time point you start to see some
diffusion of the signal away from the
area where it's supposed to be soon the
images in cells actually work a little
bit
Chris and so in this case you look at
this image and you decide that you know
this image right here is the one that
you want to choose because it's the
brightest with the least amount of
diffusion and that corresponds to 24
minutes so we would say four mouths
small intestine in this case with this
tissue sectioning protocol that we use
24 minutes is the optimal
criminalisation time for this particular
tissue and what you can see on this is
in another series of tissues that we
tested here in house you can see that
there is a range of emulation times that
are appropriate for different tissues
for example human kidneys and we found
12 minutes was optimal Mouse olfaction
village but 18 minutes was optimal now
spleen 24 minutes and the human lung
found that 36 minutes was optimal and
the human lung is actually one of these
interesting cases where you perhaps want
to repeat this experiment and go a bit
longer and verify the 36 minutes
actually is the ideal time and maybe
that you would see a better signal 40
minutes or even later than that
depending on the thickness of the tissue
and the nature of the tissue that you
have to be looking at so just some notes
of tissue optimization and something to
your number here one point other you
know this is really critical prior to
beginning the gene expression experiment
if you don't have your tissue can
fermentation conditions worked out ahead
of time you won't achieve your optimal
results and so that's what I'm really
saying this is an important part of
running the museum solution
well there's typically high levels of
reproducibility working the same tissue
from different animals so if you have
four or five mice or five humans or you
know however mean biological replicates
that you want to look at you can take
that same tissue and look across all
these different animals and will
typically be the same from the Ovation
time so you should really think there's
once for any tissue type I would point
out the caveat though if you haven't
been looking at diseases you might
notice
for instance so there are differences
between the criminalization editions for
a healthy and in these tissue that we've
noticed internally well this is
especially true if you're looking at
tumor containing tissues they typically
have very different terminals ation
conditions than the matched healthy
conditions that you might have one other
the results are subjective and the
permanent but you know that's not bad
because the termination window is fairly
wide so you're not going to see
drastically different results if you go
plus or minus one of your time points
and then I don't have that when in doubt
you should probably take the longer of
the time points if you're debating
between one or two I'll go with the
longer one and you know you'll likely
see slightly better results so now I
wanted to talk about the actual
experiment the one you're more
interested in the spatial gene
expression of experiment and you know
like I said earlier this is really kind
of the next generation of RNA speak
allowing you to see gene expression
within the context of the tissue itself
rather than doing dissociation the
workflow is fairly similar to what we
showed with the tissue optimization
except that there's now added downstream
steps on you to your library so you can
take your same tissue section fresh
frozen section that using a cryostat
I'll put it on from this slide I knew
your standard agency staining and
imaging you run the fermentation time
that you've previously determined then
do your cDNA generation
reverse transcription on this slide and
again in this case we're not using the
fluorescent nucleotides we just heat
regular nucleotides so you produce a
normal kind of full-length C DNA
molecule you can then generate your
second strand I take that off and you
can do see any implication and there's a
very very standard workflow to get you
to your sequencing ready library those
of you that are familiar with our
five-prime and three-prime single cell
products will recognize this immediately
it's almost identical that's you know
very standard across
the industry you can put those libraries
on your standard short read sequencer
and on the back end you can use the
Space Ranger pipeline and loop browser
to analyze your data and visualize
differences in gene expression across
your tissues of interest so the slide
itself this is the gene expression slide
it's a standard 25 millimeter by 75
millimeter glass slide in this case
there or capture its per slide rather
than the eight capture areas we had with
the tissue optimization slide and the
standard spacing of these capture areas
apart allows for multi-channel by penny
on so that you can fairly easily run
through are the whole slide I'm using a
multi-channel pipette you can see here
on the right that's blown-up image there
are two kinds of features on this
capture area on the first of the
barcodes are these spatially encoded
barcodes there's 4990 two unique
barcodes here they have the spot size
and about 55 micron with 100 micron
centeredness in our distance and using
this side is orange crate packing system
we can maximize the number of spots that
we can fit within this small area the
red spots that you see on the outside
are the initial frames for the frame and
this is an 8 millimeter by 8 millimeter
square area all these spots are bigger
other 100 micron spots they're 200
micron Center in the center and these
are visible in both bright field and
fluorescence channels and this allows
you to do easy automated or manual
alignments of the tissue so you can our
software will allow you to take your
bright field image and then it will
automatically tell you where your tissue
is orient you correctly and get you into
the point where you know exactly what
barcodes are under what portion of your
tissue so if you go into a bit more
detail on the as they call these in the
5000 spots each one of these spots
contains millions of these all of those
here
that look like the thing on the right
are we have a partial read one your
spatial barcode twelve base your line in
Argentine captures two points and in
each case we have millions of those
capture sequences per spot like a
biology is fairly straightforward here
but uniquely different from some of our
single-cell products and that your
captures your all those connected
directly to the array like covalent bond
and so if your partial are one your
spatial barcode your you lie in quality
teeny use that to capture the poly a
tail of mRNA do reverse transcription
followed by template switching and you
end up with a single strand full-length
cDNA molecule that has both a five-prime
and three-prime tag you can then come in
and get rid of your mRNA using a base in
this case we recommend potassium
hydroxide neutralize the solution and
then come back with your TSO primer and
you can prime the polymerization of the
second strand cDNA by using polymerase
that we provide at the end you produce
your second strand cDNA and you can come
in again with potassium hydroxide and
you can denature your second strand away
from the slide on neutralize that and
then you have a second strand that has
both you five-prime and three-prime tags
again and that can go through standard
simi amplification and the standard
downstream library preparation protocol
or that's common to several over other
products in PCR tubes and so it's really
actually pretty neat about this is that
your original molecule stays bound the
slide and so if something bad would have
happened during your sample prep you
know you losing spill your agents you
can always come back to your slide
because your original molecule is still
there and you can potentially come back
and do this whole process again without
you know losing anything any valuable
information
I was in a general workflow you know
goes like this but you know we'll go
into too much detail here if I said say
it takes a less than nine hours to run
this can you run fairly easily within a
full workday however if you don't have
nine hours to dedicate is there are
multiple stopping places throughout this
workflow where you can potentially stop
depending on the position you know from
days to weeks and still produce very
nice-looking libraries at the back end
so you can do this in a day but you
don't have to intern tissue
compatibility here at ten actually tried
numerous mouth tissues in most cases we
found that tissue thickness that's
optimal about 10 microns however
depending on the tissue type you
couldn't want to go thicker potentially
so we tried all these mouth tissues and
we've also tried the brain heart and
kidney brats each one and work very well
whereas they put is very nice looking
results that show great tissue
morphology and great gene expression
within the tissues that we tested on the
human side we've tried several different
tissues that are more interesting and
you know slightly more relevant probably
to this crew I look at things like
glioblastoma a healthy breast and
compared that to two different types of
breast cancer healthy human hearts
healthy diseased kidneys colorectal
cancer papillary carcinoma lung healthy
no flame lymph nodes
well varying tumors as well inflamed
spleens we tested using the thicknesses
on the right there but we're always
testing more tissues and I remind
everyone that your results may vary also
depending on how thick your tissue is or
the composition of tissue we found that
fatty tissues typically need to be kind
of somewhat thicker depending on the
optimal temperature your cryo stay you
might find that thicker
might be better perhaps even thinner but
all these issues work very beautifully
in our system we were able to produce
is very interesting biological results
and I'll show you some of those here at
the end so we also tried a couple of
tissues that haven't worked on the first
try and so what we've seen here is that
in human and mouse we have issues of the
skin the tissue appears to be somewhat
leaky it means there's a large
percentage transcript that actually
appear outside the tissue footprint with
the mouse pancreas we can see him in the
same leaky condition as well as the
degradation of RNA leading to a loss and
longer transcripts and this sort of
makes biological sense given the amount
of digestive enzymes that are found in
the pancreas and then finally a mouse
bone we try this in house it actually
doesn't work but it requires a
decalcification step it seems to change
the transcriptional profile somewhat and
it also requires a specialized blade for
crab sectioning and I point out that you
know don't be discouraged of these are
the tissues that you happen to be
interested in this is something that
just didn't work on the first try and we
think using a tissue optimization slides
the Shogun's Asian kit there's no reason
to think that you can't get this to work
in your hand it might just take slightly
different conditions then what we tried
so far and point out also that this is
not a complete list are there's many
many tissues that we have not tried that
may require further optimization and as
always we recommend testing new tissues
at the tissue optimization kids if it
works at the teachers optimization kit
you'll likely get good sequence results
with that condition we'll also be
providing software and visualization
tools using the Space Ranger pipeline
and the loop browser will be much more
information about that in the coming
weeks as we get a somewhat closer to
ship but as we get closer more and more
information than released on this but
suffice to say you know the high level
of automatic fiducial detection and
alignment as well as manual alignment so
in cases where you covered to me the
potential spots with your tissue we can
actually correct that by going in doing
the manual alignment as well we can
automatically detect your tissues
however if you haven't be only
interested in certain regions of your
tissue we also have a manual option that
would allow you to highlight only the
region of the tissue that you happen to
be interested in we also have a web
summary now this web summary looks very
similar to the rest of our product lines
however we do show the tissue image
within that web summary so will be a
uniquely spatial but if for those of you
that are familiar with other product
lines and our other web summaries
there'll be nothing too surprising there
this is fully integrated the loop
browser offer you're down during image
and expression analysis and like I said
more information about this will be
available shortly I also want to take
the last little bit of my talk to tell
you about two sample types that we
looked at more in-depth to really kind
of show the power of this system and
what you can do with the vizima space
with me an expression solution so this
person Alice's is the mouse olfactory
bulb and chose the mouse or factory bulb
because it has very clear and distinct
morphological features they're easy to
look at it also happens to be the first
tissue with which spatial transcriptome
include demonstrated on a paper by stall
at all in science in 2016
everyone should definitely check out
that paper it's a really amazing paper
and you know pave the way for this
product they were working on now so as
you can see here this is your H&E image
you can clearly see the tissue the
tissue as well as the fiducials in this
image and this helps us link in the
credentials to automatically align the
tissue with the barcodes that are
underneath and the only you can't see
that where the barcodes are you can zoom
in again you can gonna see these clearly
morphological regions you can see
castration you can see all the different
sections of this tissue and start
thinking about what's interesting to
look at the first thing you might want
to look at is the number of genes
interesting
this case you're seeing up to 8,000
genes per feature and you know the other
thing to point out here is that you're
not seeing many genes outside of your
teaching footprint so doing very rapidly
from lots of genes to very congenial to
no genes so as you move away from the
tissue you see some very similar genome
eyes in this case you're seeing up to
40,000 new mais per spot once you are in
these regions that have high RNA
expression so you're really seeing a lot
of new molecules here and that's really
good if you're interested in lowly
expressed genes because you'll find them
if you want to the next thing you can do
is look at a kind of spatially nitin
clustering so do you think this is
almost like a single-cell experiment
well we don't know spatially where
things are this is the graph based
clustering that you would get looking at
your 5000 spots and you can take this
spatially main clustering and you can
then overlay that back on top of the
tissue and what you see is that the
clusters all very nicely into
morphological regions so you can easily
distinguish that these morphological
regions do have unique gene expression
patterns and that you can easily
determine that using this product so if
you are interested in understanding more
about this without having kind of any
background knowledge on the Mousehole
factory bulb you can want to be top up
regulating genes in these clusters what
you can see is the culture one on the
top of gene DC 1 cluster Tunes to even
6th question 3 [ __ ] de cuatro for cluster
five clusters 6 all have unique genes
other most highly expressed in that
region and you can see that they follow
very nicely the morphological features
and you can sort of see underneath on
here stained tissue if you do happen to
know what you're looking at on this case
we look back to the style paper in 2016
I was the same invaded P&K dr. G
in case evening 12 and you can see their
special transcriptomic pattern as well
as their new mr. chemistry there in the
bottom match very very nicely to what
we're seeing here are each one of these
jeans is uniquely I mapped to a specific
region of the mouse olfactory bulb you
can also zoom in so if you look here you
can zoom in on the region and you can
see these different morphological region
striations here and you can actually
tell where the boundaries are of where
the different genes are being expressed
so you can see BC one it's kind of
expressed on the outer end here on CPT
six is more in the inner part of the
lobe but not as far in as energy in and
this gene here shines at 3 is really
interesting because you really only see
it being expressed right along this
distinct line at the very edge of the
kind of bulb there and so you can
actually you know as you zoom in closer
and closer you can see the individual
nuclei the makeup are those cells which
need different genes are being expressed
so lastly I wanted to go through an
example of a human breast invasive
lobular carcinoma and I'll point out
that I'm not a pathologist I don't know
very much about this tissue just by
looking at it you can see there's
definitely some highly concluded regions
that are likely to be interesting but
there's no clear morphology like we saw
before with the mouse or factory bulb
with a distinct region that you know are
going to be uniquely different from
other regions you can run this
experiment you can look at genes again
you're seeing over 8,000 genes per
feature and you don't see a lot of
diffusion away from this issue I look at
your mind we're seeing in this case over
80,000 you mize unique molecules that
were seen
per feature here also you can see very
high levels of gene expression in
created regions that were looking at
you can do your my especially nice
clustering in this case it identifies
eight clusters using graph based
clustering that can be overlaid on the
tissue you can see you know it doesn't
seem to follow some of this morphology
you see sort of these nucleated regions
in cluster five and cluster seven that
you were able to identify before i'll
just visually but again with no clear
morphological regions like we saw before
it's sort of unclear what's happening so
one interesting thing you can do is you
can actually go back to your spatial
named clustering and look at you know
how these questions will determine if
you're like me kind of the first thing
you notice when you look at this is this
cluster here this is I guess the sub
cluster of cluster five and but it seems
to be neat job when pretty much
everything else that we're looking at
here clustered fairly far apart from all
the rest of these clusters and using the
loop browser or what you can do and you
can highlight those specific spots that
you're interested in and you can overlay
them back onto your tissue and in this
case you can see that they all not very
clearly just region here on the right
hand side of the tissue that I
highlighted here in degree and
essentially all those spots map right
there and so then you can say alright
that's interesting but what does it
really mean is that morphologically
interesting region of the tissue and so
you can then say what are the top of
gene your top up regulated genes within
this area now as you can see that keoki
KL K 2 and K L K 3 are both up regulated
over nine fold over the rest the tissue
this area KL k two has been implicated
in 25 types of cancer including breast
carcinoma and K okay three all
pS day was a common biomarker prostate
cancer and so you can see that you know
this definitely is a region that's very
interesting in terms of its genes being
expressed as related to this carcinoma
that we're seeing and again not about
the ologies but it doesn't look that
dissimilar from some of these other
nucleated regions that you see within
the ancient image here if you want to go
into more detail you know where these
two genes can okay to kill came through
being expressed we do see some
expression in these other regions
however that expression much lower as
compared to this region of identified in
green here using those facially naive
clustering if you go in and look at kind
of the top up and down regulated genes
within this carcinoma within that
specific region you can see that almost
all of them are highly related to cancer
and have high probability that these are
involved in this carcinoma and so
without knowing anything really ahead of
time about this tissue section we can
make wickley started diving in as an
interesting biology and start
understanding gene expression of
specific tissue regions and how that
could play a part in the progression of
this disease also to conclude I hope
I've convinced you that spatial context
is critical to our understanding these
biological systems under the museum
spatial mean expression solution allows
users to repair gene expression
libraries directly from tissue sections
in one day without losing that spatial
context and then you can use the this
data and images to be and analyze them
with the space ranger pipeline and the
loop browser and these are very
biologists friendly tools you're all
none of them require any kind of
informatics background you can simply
jump into these tools and start playing
around and figuring out what's
interesting to you the tissue up in the
nation kit can and should be used to
determine and fine-tune your permanent
conditions on pretty much any tissue
type as I said we tested a lot of
tissues here at 10 next for the most
part they all seem to work really nicely
and if you look back through the spatial
transcriptomics literature there are a
whole bunch of other tissues that have
successfully been used both academically
or using the original facial
transcriptomics product and this is a
really cool discovery tool that can use
the find genes of interest really no
background knowledge of the tissues
being analyzed so it requires no
specialized instrumentation beyond the
crowds that a microscope and a sequencer
and you're all thing you should be able
to find pretty readily on your campus
and I'd also like to point out that it
doesn't really require any background
knowledge of you know pathology or you
know the tissue types there's no reason
you need to have a pathologist look at
this ahead of time basically you get all
the information you don't need to choose
a region of interest because you can
find that later on basically you can
determine what's interesting to you
after you've already done that
sequencing so with that I'd like to say
that we are taking pre-orders on this
product right now on contact your local
sales rep or FAS for more information